as you may have heard the presidential
election is now just 31
days away but this morning we're also
taking you way
way back to the days of the first
presidential elections and the
remarkable origins of four of our first
five presidents
it's the focus of a new book called the
virginia dynasty
by former second lady lynn chaney
i love the the process of research
especially
like the men she writes about lynn
cheney has led a life under a glaring
spotlight
second lady of the united states former
chair of the national endowment for the
humanities
and prolific author from contemporary
novels to children's books
and now history it's amazing if you
think about it
in this little part of the world
60 mile circle east of the blue ridge
mountains
these four amazing leaders came
the virginia dynasty is about four of
the first five men who served as
president
and how for the first 36 years of the
republic
accepting john adams single term all the
men elected were basically
neighbors george washington thomas
jefferson
james madison and james monroe people
are
very familiar with george washington and
thomas jefferson
much less so with monroe and madison why
is that
madison has been consistently
undervalued
chaney's book gives equal attention to
four figures who've received unequal
attention in history books
she calls madison the fourth president
the intellectual force
behind both the constitution and the
bill of rights
he was followed by another man also
unfamiliar to many today
what should people know about james
monroe that they don't know now
he was a pretty good president he had a
very stable cabinet
he had a reputation probably it was
somewhat justified as not being
quite as clever as his predecessors but
he learned along the way which was a
good thing
monroe madison and jefferson all
competed mightily
for the attention and respect of the
first member of the dynasty
our first leader and a bit of a loner
washington was austere
he tried to make friends but had a very
hard time doing it
people talk about you know the
loneliness at the top
uh the loneliness of leadership and i
think that
uh was part of what made washington
the way that he was he was somewhat
isolated by the role he played in the
revolution
so why did so many men who live so close
together come to lead the nation for
more than 30 years
in part their elite educations in part
because they all benefited heavily from
a southern economic system that relied
on
enslaved labor we asked cheney about
that
you don't deal with slave holding very
much in this book why
well that's not the focus of the book
though i certainly do deal with it
i think in fact it was an important
purpose of the book
to point out that these men though they
were slave holders
accomplished something uh quite amazing
they came forth with the ideas and the
ideals
that became the most powerful weapon for
doing away with slavery
cheney also doesn't talk a lot in the
book about the four men's childhoods
her own children have grown up in a
political machine
one's now become part of it wyoming
congresswoman
liz chaney currently has the third
highest position in house
gop leadership and made some headlines
this summer
your daughter has been critical of
president over his coronavirus response
and she's taken a great deal of heat
from some of her republican colleagues
over that
have you talked to her about that well i
think if i were to
to talk about liz's decisions i mean how
would you feel
if your mother were advising you on how
you could
best appear on television probably
wouldn't like it much and i'm sure liz
wouldn't like it much
moreover she knows a lot more about it
than i do
but you've been on the battlefield
plenty of times and she is now
that's correct but she's the active
member of the family cheney says the
focus of her activity
these days will remain on writing at 79
she rarely misses a day what is next for
you
you know i'm not sure i wrote children's
books for a time
i did that when dick was vice president
i thought it was a good way to stay out
of trouble
so maybe another children's book is in
the future
if my mother were advising me yes i had
a look
on television she would tell me before
doing interviews with a former second
lady to comb your hair
and look somewhat presentable so my
apologies for that but our thanks to
lynn cheney for sitting down
yeah you were blushing a bit just a bit